this is the town of Lake Arthur New
Mexico population 433 it's three and a
half hours from Albuquerque and to call
it a sleepy southwestern town would be
an understatement
this is will Norwood until recently he
was Lake Arthur's police chief Lake
Arthur was an unusual department almost
every one of Norwood's officers were
volunteers 84 and all one of those
volunteers Robert and Mercer Robert
Mercer is the fabulously wealthy
computer scientist who helped bankroll
the election of President Donald Trump
and for six years by serving as a
volunteer policeman in Lake Arthur
Mercer was getting something money alone
can't buy the right to carry a concealed
firearm anywhere in America Bloomberg's
Zack miter uncovered this latest chapter
of the many incredible but true stories
about Robert Mercer I was definitely
surprised but I'm just sort of used to
being surprised by all the interesting
things that Robert Mercer is up to so
who is Robert Mercer here's what we know
about this incredibly secretive
political kingmaker and some of the
fringe ideas he bankrolls
Robert Mercer is notoriously private as
far as we know Mercer has never spoken
publicly about his political beliefs he
really is not interested in in talking
publicly about what he believes or why
so one of the only ways to get a clearer
picture of Mercer is to follow his web
of money and a lot of that money
supports projects as far from the
mainstream as you could possibly get
that's a theme that you see with Mercer
again and again is that he's deeply
skeptical of the received wisdom and
that connects to a lot of his support
for what you might call kind of fringe
science and fringe economics ideas and
really his willingness to bankroll
people like Steve Bannon who at the time
was not considered an a-list political
player Steve Bannon led Trump's campaign
in the final months leading to the
election and of course he later moved to
the White House for years Mercer was the
money behind bannon's projects the
biggest one being Breitbart news Bannon
had this very distinct vision for a new
kind of conservative politics that would
be much more kind of populist than the
standard kind of Republican playbook
in 2011 Mercer gave the far-right
populist website ten million dollars
soon after Bannen became Breitbart
executive chairman and the site's
audience exploded Bannon really builds
this thing into a juggernaut of
conservative politics Mercer also helped
fund a ban and lead nonprofit which
published a book portraying Hillary
Clinton as corrupt it does involve the
Clintons and an enormous mining company
called uranium one this company uranium
one which controlled about 1/5 of
America's uranium giving away nuclear
capability to our enemies all of that
came from the book Clinton cash
the third big banning project that
Mercer bankrolled was Cambridge analytic
a Bannon and Mercer co-founded the
political data firm in 2013 with Mercer
giving fifteen million dollars later the
Trump campaign hired the firm to help
get Trump elected this is the Cambridge
analytical that in 2018 became the
center of a tech and political firestorm
for using the personal data of 87
million Facebook users without their
approval
and those are just some of the political
projects that Mercer's funded as a
family the Mercer's have given more than
40 million dollars to GOP candidates in
super PACs since 2010 outside of
politics some of the more quirky ideas
that Mercer has funded include a
scientist in Oregon who has a gigantic
stockpile of human urine with the goal
of extending human life a counter
conference in Jackson Hole Wyoming
promoting the use of the gold standard
and he gives millions to multiple groups
attacking the science of global warming
Mercer now 71 wasn't always rich and
able to bankroll his idiosyncratic views
he grew up in New Mexico with an
interest in computers through his mid to
late 40s he was kind of like a research
almost like a professor he worked at IBM
and he was a researcher he was
responsible for doing really interesting
cutting-edge work but he wasn't a
zillionaire at IBM he was part of a team
laying the groundwork for modern-day
speech recognition software like Google
Translate it wasn't until his late 40s
when he left IBM for Renaissance
Technologies arguably the most
successful hedge fund in the history of
the world
Mercer became co-ceo of the fund in 2009
making him a very wealthy man the
Bloomberg billionaires index values
Mercer's well that almost a billion
dollars which brings us back to Lake
Arthur and the one thing Mercer's money
alone couldn't buy it seemed to me like
a story about the lengths that a person
of really astonishing memes will go to
to get something that they otherwise
couldn't get the right to carry his gun
anywhere in the US Mercer is a serious
gun enthusiast to give you a picture he
co-owns a gun company bought the largest
private collection of these machine guns
and has a factory in South Carolina that
makes assault style rifles we also know
when he built his house which is the
sort of sprawling Palace on the North
Shore of Long Island he actually
included in at a pistol range right
right in the basement of his home but
getting a concealed carry permit where
Mercer lives is incredibly difficult and
even if he did get a permit he would not
have been able to take his gun to New
York City and other states until 2004
when Congress passed a law which says
police officers can carry concealed guns
in any state since then small Police
Department's around the country
including the one in Lake Arthur have
been rumored to hand out badges to in
exchange for cash the so-called badge
factories after Businessweek spotlighted
the Lake Arthur Department the mayor
quickly shut it down we still don't know
exactly what was going on in Lake Arthur
what we do know is that during the six
years he wore that badge
Mercer supported the town generously so
after all that who really is Robert
Mercer I think he's kind of more
whimsical than most people would imagine
I think he here's an interesting idea
and he says this is something worth
exploring and let's give it a shot
you